Vladimir Putin has won the election in Russia.
You won it in a landslide,
something like 88%.
Now, that's gotta be relatively easy to do
when you can make your opponents
past tense. He rose to power in 1999 after making roughly, uh,
the lieutenant colonel or O5 equivalent in the KGB.
Like a Russian Jason Bourne kind of guys.
Also pretty skilled at judo,
and a lot of people don't know that
it's a martial art predicated on throwing your opponent.
One of Vladimir Putin's primary goals
has always been to bring Russia back to its former glory,
or what he believes is back to its former glory.
He did state in an address he gave after winning the election
that the rest of the world,
specifically the countries in the west,
can anticipate and emboldened Russia.
He said, in war or in peace,
we can anticipate and emboldened Russia.
What I believe that means is
they're gonna double down on a lot of the stuff
that's not looked at favorably in the international community.
Badamir Putin winning this election and.
And guaranteeing himself another six years in power.
If he makes it all the way through the term,
which there's no reason to believe that he wouldn't,
he will overtake Joseph Stalin
as the longest serving leader in Russian history.
The overwhelmingly won the popular vote.
It was like 87 or 88%.
This was met with significant protest.
He said he would continue to try and resolve the
Special military operation
happening in Ukraine.
And then work to empower and prioritize the Russian military.
I don't think we're seeing them stopping operations in Ukraine
anytime soon. That is definitely not the vibe that he is giving.
I also strongly believe that as long as he is able to,
he is going to remain in power.
He's 71 years old,
so, I mean, he's got a lot of life left in him.